THE IS NOW IN SESSION. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MAIN SHINE NOTICES THE
ABSENCE OF A QUORUM, THE
SERGEANT AT ARMS WILL PREPARE
THE CHAMBER BRING IN THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. THE CLERK WILL CALL THE
ROLL ADDIS AGAR CURRY, ALANIS
ALVAREZ ARAMBULA BEANS B, KEN
BENNETT BERMAN. BURNER. BONTA
BRIAN CALDERONE, JUAN CARRILLO,
WENDY CARRILLO CERVANTES, CHEN
CONNOLLY, DOLLY DAVIES DIXON
ACEI FLORA MIKE FONG, VINCE FONG
FRIEDMAN, GABRIEL GALLAGHER
GARCIA. GIBSON GRAYSON, HANEY
HART HOLDEN. HOOVER IRWIN.
JACKSON JOAN SAWYER, KRA LACKEY
LEE LOW LOWENTHAL, MAINS SHINE.
MATHIS MCCARTY, MINNER MISOI WIN
ORTEGA, PACO PAPIN, JIM
PATTERSON, JOE PATTERSON,
PELLERIN PETRIE-NORRIS CORK,
SILVA RAMOS, RENDON REYES
LUZ RIVAS RODRIGUEZ RUBIO
SANCHEZ SANTIAGO SHIAVO SOA Tð.
VALENCIA VIAUD WALDRON, WALLACE
WARD, WEBER, WIX WILSON WOOD
ZER, MR SPEAKER.
WHEREVER YOU. MEMBERS. A QUORUM
IS PRESENT. WE ASK OUR VISITORS
AND GUESTS IN THE REAR OF THE
CHAMBER AND IN THE GALLERY TO
PLEASE STAND FOR THE PRAYER AND
THE FLAG SALUTE. TODAY'S PRAYER
WILL BE OFFERED BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GRAYSON. PLEASE JOIN IN
TODAY'S PRAYER. ALMIGHTY GOD.
WHOSE LOVE IS UNCONDITIONAL,
WHOSE MERCY IS EVERLASTING,
WHOSE GRACE IS SUFFICIENT. FOR
WHICH RIGHTEOUSNESS AND JUSTICE
ARE THE FOUNDATION OF YOUR
THRONE. GRANT'S WISDOM THAT WE
MAY DEFEND THOSE WITHOUT AND DO
JUSTICE TO THE AFFLICTED THAT WE
MAY LEARN TO DO WELL SEEK
JUDGMENT, RELIEVE THE OPPRESSED
AND PLEAD FOR THOSE WHOSE VOICES
GO UNHEARD THAT YOUR PEACE THAT
GOES BEYOND ALL UNDERSTANDING
REIGN OVER US THIS DAY AS WE
GIVE ALL GLORY AND HONOR UNTO
YOU. AMEN. THANK YOU. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER, GRAYSON. AS SOME OF MY
MAIN SHINE WILL LEAD U S¼ IN THE
PLEDGE. PLEASE JOIN ME IN THE
PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE. I PLEDGE
ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG. UNITED
STATES OF AMERICA. RIGHT? YOU
MAY BE SEATED. READING OF THE
PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL. SUMMARY
CHAMBER, SACRAMENTO WEDNESDAY
MARCH 23RD 20 CURRYS THAT THE
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL BE DISPENSED WITH
PRESENTATIONS AND PETITIONS.
THERE ARE NONE. INTRODUCTION AND
REFERENCE OF BILLS WILL BE
DEFERRED. REPORTS OF COMMITTEES
WILL BE DEEMED RED AND
AMENDMENTS DEEMED ADOPTED.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR.
THERE ARE NONE. MESSAGES FROM
THE SENATE. THERE ARE NONE.
MEMBERS BEFORE WE BEGIN THE
JOINT CONVENTION, PLEASE CLEAR
YOUR DESKS AND PUT ANY ITEMS YOU
MAY HAVE INSIDE YOUR DESK.
AGAIN. PLEASE CLEAR THE TOPS OF
YOUR DESK. MOVING TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS. TODAY'S ABSENCES
WILL BE DEEMED READ AND PRINTED
IN THE JOURNAL. MAJORITY LEADER
AGUIAR-CURRY. YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
FOR PROCEDURAL MOTIONS. GOOD
AFTERNOON, MR SPEAKER. I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO SUSPEND
ASSEMBLY RULE 118 A TO ALLOW
SPEAKER REVS TO HAVE GUESTS ON
THE FLOOR AND AT THE ROSTRUM
TODAY. THE OBJECTION. SUCH SHALL
BE THE ORDER.
MEMBERS AND GUESTS. WE WILL NOW
RECESS THE REGULAR SESSION AND
CONVENE. UH, THE JOINT
CONVENTION. THANKFULLY, EVERYONE
IS SEATED. SO AS WE ARE AWARE,
THE CHIEF JUSTICE AND THE
ASSOCIATE, UH, JUSTICES OF THE
SUPREME COURT OF CALIFORNIA HAVE
ARRIVED. SO I'M APPOINTING A
JOINT, UH, A COMMITTEE TO ESCORT
THE JUSTICES TO THE ROSTRUM. THE
FOLLOWING MEMBERS, PLEASE
RETIRE. TO THE REAR OF THE
CHAMBER. ITS ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
BONTA CHOLERA. MAINS, SHINE AND
PACHECO SENATORS DE RAZZO.
SEYARTO UMBERG AND WAHAB.
JOINT ESCORT COMMITTEE. PLEASE
ESCORT THE CHIEF JUSTICE AND THE
ASSOCIATE JUSTICES OF THE
SUPREME COURT OF CALIFORNIA TO
THE ROSTRUM.
SO WELCOME TO ALL OUR GUESTS
HERE TODAY, INCLUDING, UH, OUR
GOVERNOR, MR GAVIN NEWSOM. WE
ALSO HAVE A MEMBER OF THE BOARD
OF EQUALIZATION, MS SALLY LEVER.
WE ALSO WELCOME UH, THE OTHER
ELECTED OFFICIALS AND GUESTS
FROM OUR LEGAL, UH, OUR
COMMUNITY AND THE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL OF CALIFORNIA. IT IS NOW
MY PLEASURE TO INTRODUCE THE
PRESIDENT PRO TEM OF THE
CALIFORNIA SENATE, MR MIKE
MCGUIRE. WE. WELL. GOOD
AFTERNOON. MR SPEAKER INTO OUR
ASSEMBLY COLLEAGUES. THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR HOSTING US TODAY. MR
GOVERNOR. IT IS ALWAYS GOOD TO
SEE YOU. WE ARE GRATEFUL THAT
YOU'RE HERE. FIRST AND FOREMOST,
IT IS AN HONOR TO BE WITH EACH
AND EVERY ONE OF YOU THIS
AFTERNOON ON THIS SPECIAL
OCCASION. OF CALIFORNIA STATE OF
JUDICIARY. WE WANT TO RECOGNIZE
ALL OF THE SUPERIOR COURT JUDGES
FROM ACROSS THE GOLDEN STATE WHO
HAVE TRAVELED FAR AND WIDE AND
JOINED US FOR CHIEF JUSTICE
GUERRERO'S ADDRESS. THANK YOU
FOR BEING HERE. CAN WE PLEASE
GIVE A ROUND OF APPLAUSE TO OUR
SUPERIOR COURT JUDGES WHO ARE
HERE TODAY?
AT THIS TIME COLLEAGUES WE WOULD
NOW LIKE TO INTRODUCE EACH OF
THE CALIFORNIA SUPREME COURT
ASSOCIATE JUSTICES DISTINGUISHED
GUESTS COLLEAGUES. LET'S WELCOME
TO THE CHAMBERS. JUSTICE CAROL
CORRIGAN. JUSTICE GOODWIN LIU.
JUSTICE LEANDRA KRUGER. JUSTICE
JOSHUA GROBAN. JUSTICE MARTIN
JENKINS. INJUSTICE. KELLY EVANS.
WE ARE GRATEFUL TO EACH AND
EVERY ONE OF YOU FOR YOUR TIRES,
WORK AND YOUR COMMITMENT TO
EQUAL JUSTICE FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN OF THE ASSEMBLY AND
THE SENATE. WE ALSO WOULD LIKE
TO EXTEND A WARM WELCOME TO THE
CALIFORNIA SUPREME COURT. CHIEF
JUSTICE MS PATRICIA GUERRERO,
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN.
WHEN JUSTICE GUERRERO TOOK ON
THE ROLE OF LEADING OUR HIGHEST
COURT LAST YEAR, SHE SET
PRIORITIES FOR THE SUPREME
COURT. THEY ARE AS FUNDS
ENHANCING PUBLIC CONFIDENCE IN
THE JUDICIARY, INCREASING
TRANSPARENCY AND IMPROVING
ACCESS TO OUR JUSTICE SYSTEM.
AND THE CHIEF JUSTICE HAS
CERTAINLY FOLLOWED THROUGH ON
EACH OF THESE COMMITMENTS AND
WORKS DAY AND NIGHT TO ENSURE TO
ENSURE ALL CALIFORNIANS HAVE
EQUAL, UH, EQUAL ACCESS TO OUR
COURT SYSTEM. AND I THINK THAT
YOU WILL AGREE WITH ME TODAY.
CHIEF JUSTICE GUERRERO. SHE IS A
TRAILBLAZER AS THE FIRST MEMBER
FIRST MEMBER OF THE LATINO
COMMUNITY TO HOLD THE POSITION
OF CHIEF JUSTICE. SHE IS
INCORPORATED A SPECIAL FOCUS ON
FAIRNESS ON EQUITY AND INCLUSION
IN AN EFFORT TO ENSURE THAT OUR
COURT SYSTEM REFLECTS THE
DIVERSE COMMUNITIES IT SERVES. I
KNOW THAT IT CAN SPEAK FOR
SPEAKER RIVAS AND MYSELF. IT IS
AN HONOR TO BE ABLE TO WORK WITH
THE CHIEF JUSTICE AND THE
JUDICIARY, AND WE LOOK FORWARD
TO OUR CONTINUED PARTNERSHIP AND
WORK ON BEHALF OF THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA. NOW IT IS WITH DEEP
RESPECT. WE TURN IT OVER TO THE
29TH, LEADER OF OUR STATE'S
HIGHEST COURT, AS THEY SAY IN
THE COURTROOM ALL RISE. WE
WELCOME CALIFORNIA'S CHIEF
JUSTICE PATRICIA GUERRERO, TO
PROVIDE CALIFORNIA'S ANNUAL
STATE OF JUDICIARY ADDRESS. THIS
IS NOT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. SENATE
PRESIDENT PRO TEM MCGUIRE
SPEAKER REVIS. DISTINGUISHED
STATEWIDE CONSTITUTIONAL
OFFICERS AND GUESTS AND, OF
COURSE, GOVERNOR NEWSOM. THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
DELIVER MY STATE OF THE
JUDICIARY ADDRESS TO A JOINT
SESSION OF THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATURE THIS TIME FROM YOUR
OTHER HOUSE, THE STATE ASSEMBLY.
I GUESS YOU CAN SAY THIS IS NOT
MY FIRST RODEO. ALTHOUGH IT
LOOKS MUCH DIFFERENT FROM THE
ONES I'M USED TO GROWING UP. I
JOIN YOU TODAY IN THE SECOND
YEAR OF MY 12 YEAR TERM OF
OFFICE. REPRESENTING A JUDICIARY
THAT IS STRONG AND RESILIENT.
ONE THAT IS COMMITTED TO SERVING
ALL THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA.
ENHANCING ACCESS TO JUSTICE AND
PROTECTING THE RULE OF LAW IN
OUR CONSTITUTIONAL DEMOCRACY. I
ALSO JOIN YOU TODAY AS NÓ LONGER
THE NEWEST LEADER OF A STATE
BRANCH OF GOVERNMENT,
CONGRATULATIONS TO SPEAKER REVIS
AND SENATE PRESIDENT PRO Tð
MCGUIRE, WHO YOU RECENTLY
WELCOMED TO THEIR NEW POSITIONS.
AND THERE'S LIKE MINE WAS A
SMOOTH TRANSITION OF LEADERSHIP
THAT ENABLES US TO CONTINUE TO
PURSUE THE OBJECTIVES AND VALUES
OF OUR RESPECTIVE BRANCHES OF
GOVERNMENT. OUR PRESENCE HERE
TODAY DEMONSTRATES THAT GOOD
GOVERNMENT DOES WORK. THAT
COLLABORATION AND COOPER
OPERATION. MUTUAL RESPECT. AND A
SHARED COMMITMENT TO PUBLIC
SERVICE CAN DELIVER THREE BRANCH
SOLUTIONS TO BENEFIT ALL
CALIFORNIANS. THAT IS WHY I
REMAIN OPTIMISTIC FOR THE
JUDICIAL BRANCH AND FOR OUR
STATE. I'M VERY PROUD TO BE
JOINED HERE TODAY BY MY
COLLEAGUES ON THE CALIFORNIA
SUPREME COURT OR COURT EXECUTIVE
OFFICER AND OUR COURT STAFF.
JUDGES JUSTICES AND COURT
EXECUTIVES FROM LOCAL COURTS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE, THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL, THE CALIFORNIA
JUDGES ASSOCIATION, THE BENCH
BAR COALITION AND OUR JUSTICE
SYSTEM, PARTNERS AND
STAKEHOLDERS. THROUGH THIS LAST
YEAR OF LISTENING TO THEM
DELIBERATING WITH THEM SEEKING
SOLUTIONS WITH THEM. AND
STRIVING TO IMPROVE THE
ADMINISTRATION OF JUSTICE. THEY
HAVE ONLY GROWN IN MY ESTEEM.
TODAY IS A SCHOOL DAY. SO MY
BIGGEST SUPPORTER MY HUSBAND,
JOE, AND OUR TWO GREATEST
SOURCES OF PRIDE ARE TWO SONS,
ANTHONY AND CHRISTOPHER ARE
WATCHING REMOTELY, OR THEY SAID
THEY WOULD TRY. I'LL QUIZ THEM
LATER. WHEN I ADDRESSED YOU LAST
YEAR, MY FOCUS WAS ON THE
CONTINUITY OF BRANCH OPERATIONS
IN A YEAR OF TRANSITION, AND SO
NOW, I WOULD LIKE TO UPDATE YOU
ON SOME OF THE PRIORITIES THAT I
MENTIONED LAST YEAR. FIRST
SAFEGUARDING AND ENHANCING
PUBLIC CONFIDENCE IN THE
JUDICIARY. EARLIER THIS MONTH,
WE OPENED APPLICATIONS FOR THIS
YEAR'S CIVIC LEARNING AWARDS FOR
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC SCHOOLS COS.
SPONSORED BY STATE
SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION TONY THURMOND. SINCE
THE AWARDS WERE FIRST PRESENTED
IN 2012. WE RECOGNIZED OVER 5500
AND 18 PUBLIC SCHOOLS OF ALL
GRADE LEVELS THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA FOR ADVANCING CIVIC
EDUCATION. THROUGH OUR JUDGES IN
THE CLASSROOM PROGRAM. JUST LAST
YEAR, WE SCHEDULED A 230 VISITS
BY JUDGES TO SCHOOLS ACROSS THE
STATE, BOTH IN PERSON AND
REMOTELY. I PARTICIPATED IN THIS
PROGRAM MYSELF, BUT I CAN TELL
YOU FIRST HAND THAT IT'S A TRULY
REWARDING EXPERIENCE FOR THE
JUDGES, TEACHERS AND STUDENTS.
CIVIC LEARNING TEACHES STUDENTS
ABOUT THEIR DEMOCRACY AND
DEVELOP SKILLS FOR THEIR FUTURE
LIVES. SUCH AS CRITICAL
THINKING, PROBLEM SOLVING. IT
TEACHES THEM HOW TO BE ENGAGED
TO COMMUNICATE AND COLLABORATE
WITH ONE ANOTHER AND TO
DEMONSTRATE CREATIVITY,
INITIATIVE AND INNOVATION. AND
IT PROMOTES ACADEMIC ACHIEVEMENT
, HELPING STUDENTS REMAIN
INVOLVED AND COMMITTED TO
ONGOING LEARNING. RECENTLY I
ANNOUNCED THE NEXT PHASE OF OUR
POWER OF DEMOCRACY CIVIC
LEARNING INITIATIVE. THIS EFFORT
WILL BE LED BY WHAT I LIKE TO
CALL CIVIC LEARNING, PIONEER AND
STALWART ADMINISTRATIVE
PRESIDING JUSTICE JUDITH
MCCONNELL OF THE FOURTH DISTRICT
COURT OF APPEAL. TOGETHER WITH
JUDGE JULIA ALIMENTO, WHO HAS
ALSO BEEN VERY ACTIVE IN THIS
AREA WITH SANTA CLARA SUPERIOR
COURT. THE VISION OF THIS
INITIATIVE IS TO EXPAND CIVIC
LEARNING ABOUT OUR THREE
BRANCHES OF GOVERNMENT, BUT I
CONFESS WITH THE FOCUS ON THE
JUDICIAL BRANCH. IN EVERY
DISTRICT IN EVERY SCHOOL AND FOR
EVERY CHILD IN CALIFORNIA. WE
WANT ALL KIDS SITTING IN THE
CLASSROOMS TODAY. TO BE ACTIVELY
ENGAGED IN OUR DEMOCRACY.
THROUGH THESE PROGRAMS. I
BELIEVE THAT NOT ONLY WILL IT
ENHANCE THE CONFIDENCE IN THE
JUDICIARY, BUT IN OUR GOVERNMENT
AS A WHOLE. THE NEXT PRIORITY. I
WANT TO UPDATE YOU ON IS OUR
ONGOING WORK TO INCREASE ACCESS
TO JUSTICE, AND THAT INCLUDES
INCREASING ACCESS THROUGH THE
USE OF TECHNOLOGY. IN RESPONSE
TO THE JUDICIAL BRANCHES,
CONCERNS ABOUT FINES AND FEES,
CREATING A DEBTOR'S PRISON FOR
LOW INCOME CALIFORNIANS WHO ARE
STRUGGLING WITH DEBT FROM
TRAFFIC AND OTHER INFRACTION
VIOLATIONS. WE LAUNCHED AN
ABILITY TO PAY PILOT PROJECT
KNOWN AS MY CITATIONS. THIS WAS
IN APRIL 2019 WITH FIVE SUPERIOR
COURTS, PARTNERING WITH THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL. THE ONLINE
TOOL OFFERS LOW INCOME DRIVERS
AND EASY WAY TO REQUEST A LOWER
PENALTY, A PAYMENT PLAN OR
COMMUNITY SERVICE. AND INITIAL
GRANT FROM THE U S¼ DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE WITH ENHANCED BY ALL
OF YOU TO FUND US. MY CITATIONS
ALSO ENABLES CALIFORNIANS TO
INTERACT WITH THE COURT IN A
MORE EFFICIENT WAY. WE HAVE A
NEW MODULE THAT ALLOWS LITIGANTS
TO CONTEST ELIGIBLE TRAFFIC
CITATIONS BY SUBMITTING A
WRITTEN STATEMENT AND UPLOADING
THEIR EVIDENCE ONLINE, SAVING
THEM TRIPS TO THE COURT. AND NEW
LANGUAGES HAVE ALSO BEEN ADDED
TO ENGLISH AND SPANISH,
INCLUDING CHINESE AND VIETNAMESE
SO FAR. THROUGH THE END OF 2020
THREE MORE THAN 128,000 ABILITY
TO PAY REQUEST HAVE BEEN
SUBMITTED BY OVER 91,000
CALIFORNIANS. WITH OUTSTANDING
FINES AND FEES BEING REDUCED BY
MORE THAN HALF FROM 71 MILLION
TO 34 POINT THREE MILLION. I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO KEEP IN
MIND THAT THE DEMOGRAPHICS OF
THE PEOPLE THAT WE'RE HELPING
WITH THESE PROGRAMS NEARLY 47%
OF COURT USERS ACCESSING THE
TOOL REPORTED THAT THEY RECEIVED
PUBLIC BENEFITS. AND OVER, 89%
REPORTED INCOMES AT OR BELOW
250% OF THE FEDERAL POVERTY
LEVEL. AND THE RESULTS OF THE
PILOT PROGRAM ARE PROMISING.
THEY DEMONSTRATED THAT CASES
THAT WERE GRANTED A REDUCTION
THROUGH THIS TOOL HAD A 61%
SUCCESS RATE FOR FULL REPAYMENT.
I'M PLEASED TO SAY THE 4 TO 3
COURTS WHO HAVE DEPLOYED THE
PROGRAM. SO FAR, WE'LL SOON BE
JOINED BY THE 15 REMAINING
COURTS TO ACHIEVE FULL
DEPLOYMENT THIS YEAR. OK? THANK
YOU. THE THIRD PRIORITY I WANT
TO REPORT ON IS INCREASING
TRANSPARENCY, IMPROVING
EFFICIENCIES, AS WAS MENTIONED
AND INCREASING PRODUCTIVITY
WITHOUT SACRIFICING QUALITY.
CASE FLOW MANAGEMENT IS AN
IMPORTANT PROCESS IN MEETING
THESE OBJECTIVES AND PROVIDING
TIMELY ACCESS TO JUSTICE. FOR
THE CALIFORNIA SUPREME COURT.
WE'VE INSTITUTED INTERNAL
TARGETS FOR OUR COURT TO MEET
OUR ANNUAL NUMBER OF OPINIONS
HAS TRENDED UP, AND WE'RE ALSO
WORKING OUR WAY THROUGH SOME
IMPORTANT LANDMARK NEW LAWS SUCH
AS THE RACIAL JUSTICE ACT, WHICH
IS IMPACTING OUR WORKFLOW. THE
COURTS OF APPEAL STATEWIDE HAVE
IMPLEMENTED A MONITORING SYSTEM
TO MANAGE APPELLATE CASE LOAD
INEQUITIES AND ENSURE THAT THEY,
TOO, ARE PROMPTLY RESOLVING
CASES. KEITH FLOW, MANAGEMENT
AND TIME TO DISPOSITION. IT'S
ALSO AN IMPORTANT TOOL FOR OUR
TRIAL COURT. DATA MANAGEMENT AND
ANALYTICS HELP THEM TO MANAGE
CASELOADS. PROVIDE INTERPRETER
COVERAGE AND MAKE JURY DUTY MORE
EFFICIENT. SOMETHING MY HUSBAND
REMINDED ME OF. IT'S IMPORTANT
WHEN HE SERVED RECENTLY. IT ALSO
INFORMS HOW THEY CAN WORK BEST
WITH THEIR JUSTICE SYSTEM
PARTNERS. FROM THE CLERK'S
WINDOW TO FINAL DISPOSITIONS AND
EVERYWHERE IN BETWEEN. CASE FLOW
MANAGEMENT IS CRITICAL FOR THE
PUBLIC. WE SERVE WITH THE
RESOURCES THAT YOU PROVIDE.
PLEASE KEEP PROVIDING THEM. THE
RESOURCES YOU PROVIDE ARE OF
COURSE CRUCIAL. I WOULD NEXT
LIKE TO TOUCH UPON OUR PRIORITY
WITH RESPECT TO ADVOCATING FOR A
STABLE BUDGET THAT THE JUDICIAL
BRANCH CAN COUNT ON TO MAKE
PUBLIC ACCESS TO JUSTICE, A
REALITY FOR ALL 58 COUNTIES FOR
THIS BUDGET YEAR. I'M GRATEFUL
FOR GOVERNOR NEWSOM'S CONTINUED
SUPPORT OF OUR MISSION TO
ADVANCE ACCESS TO JUSTICE AND
FOR PROTECTING ESSENTIAL FUNDING
FOR CRITICAL PROGRAMS AND
SERVICES. THANK YOU. AND YES, WE
KNOW DURING THESE CHALLENGING
BUDGET TIMES THAT, ALONG WITH
THE REST OF STATE GOVERNMENT,
THE JUDICIAL BRANCH MUST BE PART
OF THE SOLUTION. PART OF THE
SOLUTION TO CLOSE THE STATEWIDE
BUDGET DEFICIT. WE ARE COMMITTED
TO WORKING WITH THE GOVERNOR'S
ADMINISTRATION AND WITH THE
LEGISLATURE IN THE COMING MONTH
AS PLANS FOR THE BUDGET ACT ARE
FINALIZED. THIS GOAL IS DIRECTLY
REFLECTED IN WHAT WE CALL THE
STRATEGIC PLAN FOR CALIFORNIA'S
JUDICIAL BRANCH. FOR ME.
PLANNING IS AN IMPORTANT
DISCIPLINE. I THINK ANYONE WHO
KNOWS ME KNOWS THAT I LIKE
STRUCTURE AND I LIKE RULES. THE
STRATEGIC PLAN PROVIDES THIS FOR
THE JUDICIAL BRANCH. IT'S THE
FOUNDATIONAL DOCUMENT FOR US.
SINCE THE FIRST STRATEGIC PLAN
WAS DEVELOPED IN 1992, THE
PROCESS HAS SERVED TO ARTICULATE
OUR MISSION AND DIRECTION. SAID
OUR GOVERNANCE STRUCTURES AND
PRIORITIES AND HELPED US TO
NAVIGATE SOME OF THE MOST
SIGNIFICANT REFORMS,
IMPROVEMENTS AND CHALLENGES IN
THE HISTORY OF CALIFORNIA'S
COURT SYSTEM. A PERIODIC
INTERVALS. WE'VE UPDATED OUR
LONG TERM GOALS AS CALIFORNIA
AND THE NEEDS OF ITS RESIDENTS
HAVE EVOLVED. MOST RECENTLY IN
DECEMBER. 2022 THE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL AMENDED OUR NUMBER ONE
STRATEGIC GOAL OF ACCESS,
FAIRNESS AND DIVERSITY TO ADD
INCLUSION. ALTHOUGH THIS MAY
SEEM LIKE A SMALL CHANGE, AS ONE
OF OUR COUNCIL MEMBERS SHARED AT
THE TIME. AS IMPORTANT AS
DIVERSITY IS, IF YOU'RE NOT
INCLUDED, IT DOESN'T MATTER. SO
WE SAW THIS AS AN OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK OUT LOUDER AND MAKE MORE
EXPLICIT THE BRANCHES COMMITMENT
TO AN INCLUSIVE COURT SYSTEM IN
WHICH ALL INDIVIDUALS ARE AND
FEEL RESPECTED AND ENGAGED AND
THEIR CONTRIBUTIONS ARE VALUED.
AND THIS FIRST GOAL. GUIDES ALL
FACETS OF THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL'S
REVIEW ANALYSIS AND
DELIBERATIONS. WE HAVE ONE NEW
MEMBER OF THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL.
I'M VERY PLEASED TO BE JOINED
HERE TODAY DURING WOMEN'S
HISTORY MONTH BY THE COUNCIL'S
NEW ADMINISTRATIVE DIRECTOR,
SHELLY CURRAN.
SHELLY IS THE FIRST WOMAN TO
HOLD THIS PERMANENT LEADERSHIP
ROLE AT THE COUNCIL AND THE
FIRST OPENLY L GB Tð Q PLUS
PERSON TO HOLD THIS STATEWIDE
OFFICE. SHELLY JOINED THE
COUNCIL FROM THE LEGISLATURE,
WHERE SHE WAS PRINCIPAL
CONSULTANT TO TWO CALIFORNIA
SENATE PRESIDENTS PRO TEM
ADDRESSING THE COUNCIL FOLLOWING
ITS VOTE TO CONFIRM HER
APPOINTMENT. SHELLY SHARED HER
PHILOSOPHY ABOUT PUBLIC SERVICE
AND WORKING IN GOVERNMENT. I'M
SURE IT WILL RESONATE STRONGLY
WITH YOU JUST AS IT DID WITH ME.
SHE SHARED THAT SHE SUBSCRIBES
TO THE WORLD WAR, TWO MEANING OF
THE PHRASE GOOD ENOUGH FOR
GOVERNMENT WORK. WHEN THAT
MEANT, AS SHE DESCRIBES IT, THE
BEST THE HIGHEST STANDARDS, THE
BENCHMARK FOR WHICH TO STRIVE
THOSE SAME PRINCIPLES GUIDE US
IN IMPLEMENTING THE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL'S OTHER STRATEGIC GOALS
FOR THE BRANCH. ONE GOAL HAS
PARTICULAR SALIENCE THESE DAYS.
AND THAT IS MODERNIZATION OF
MANAGEMENT AND ADMINISTRATION.
WITH RESPECT TO THIS GOAL, SOME
MODERNIZATION IS VOLUNTARY. SOME
IS DISRUPTIVE AND THRUST UPON US
. AND YOU CAN GUESS WHERE A I
FALLS IN THAT SPECTRUM. EITHER
WAY CHANGE IS THE INEVITABLE
RESULT. I DON'T RECOMMEND THAT
ANYONE SHOUT INTO THEIR PHONES,
WIN MY CASE OR WRITE MY BRIEF.
BUT SOCIETY GOVERNMENT AND
THEREFORE OUR COURT SYSTEM MUST
ADDRESS THE MANY ISSUES AND
QUESTIONS PRESENTED BY THE
DEVELOPING FIELD OF ARTIFICIAL
INTELLIGENCE. WE MUST DO THIS IN
A CAREFUL AND DELIBERATIVE
FASHION. I HAVE ASKED
ADMINISTRATIVE PRESIDING JUSTICE
MARY GREENWOOD AND JUDGE ARTURO
CASTRO TO HELP LEAD THE BRANCH'S
EFFORTS TO IDENTIFY THE
FOUNDATIONAL QUESTIONS THAT MUST
BE ASKED. AS WE CONSIDER THE
OPPORTUNITIES AND CHALLENGES
THAT ARE ASSOCIATED WITH A. I
THEIR EFFORTS WILL FACILITATE
HOW WE CONSIDER WHAT MIGHT BE
APPROPRIATE USES OF A I IN
RELATION TO THE JUDICIARY WITH
THE GUIDING PRINCIPLE OF
SAFEGUARDING THE INTEGRITY OF
THE JUDICIAL PROCESS. ANOTHER
ISSUE OF FOCUS AND SERIOUS
CONCERN TO US ALL IS CLIMATE
CHANGE, AND ITS ASSOCIATED
IMPACTS. THE JUDICIAL BRANCHES,
EARLY EDUCATION FOCUS ON LAW AND
PROCESS RELATED TO THE
CALIFORNIA ENVIRONMENTAL UH,
QUALITY ACT, BUT IT'S NOW
EXPANDED TO INCLUDE
ENVIRONMENTAL SCIENCE AND THE
RELATED AND OFTEN HIGHLY COMPLEX
LITIGATION ISSUES THAT JUDGES
ARE INCREASINGLY BEING ASKED TO
ADDRESS. WITH THE SUPPORT OF THE
LEGISLATURE. WE'RE EMBARKING ON
A MORE COMPREHENSIVE WATER AND
ENVIRONMENTAL LAW EDUCATION
FOCUS. THAT JUDICIAL BRANCH IS
PLAYING ITS PART AND SUPPORTING
ACTION AND SOLUTIONS FOR OUR
STATE IN THESE IMPORTANT AREAS
AND THROUGH OTHER MODERNIZATION
AND SERVICE INITIATIVE. NÓ
DISCUSSION OF MODERNIZATION IS
COMPLETE WITHOUT A DISCUSSION.
AS YOU KNOW OF REMOTE
TECHNOLOGY. YOU KNEW IT WAS
COMING, RIGHT? COURT USERS
THEMSELVES ARE CHOOSING TO
ACCESS THESE NEW SERVICES AND
TOOLS, INCLUDING 24 7 E, FLING
ACCESS TO ONLINE RECORDS AND
RESEARCH, SELF-HELP RESOURCES
AND, OF COURSE, REMOTE
APPEARANCES. I WANT YOU TO ALL
KNOW, ACCESSING COURT SERVICES
REMOTELY WORKS. WE KNOW THIS
FROM COURT USERS AND STAFF
ALIKE. A RECENT JUDICIAL COUNCIL
REPORT ON THIS ISSUE SHOWED US
THAT THERE WERE ABOUT 100 AND
50,000 REMOTE CIVIL PROCEEDINGS
CONDUCTED STATEWIDE IN ONE MONTH
EACH MONTH. MORE THAN 90% OF THE
COURT USERS AND 98% OF COURT
STAFF REPORTED A POSITIVE
EXPERIENCES AND VERY FEW
TECHNICAL ISSUES REPORTED AS
ALWAYS, MORE WORK REMAINS TO BE
DONE, BUT WE CAN BUILD ON THESE
SUCCESSES. ADDRESSING REMOTE
ACCESS IS ONE EXAMPLE OF
EFFECTIVE THREE BRANCH SOLUTIONS
TO BETTER SERVE THE STATE.
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE CARE ACT,
OF COURSE, IS ANOTHER EXAMPLE OF
THE THREE BRANCH SOLUTION MODEL
WORKING SUCCESSFULLY. TO DATE.
WE HAVE EIGHT COURTS WHO HAVE
IMPLEMENTED THE NEW CARE COURT
PROGRAM TO HELP DELIVER MENTAL
HEALTH TREATMENT AND SUPPORT
SERVICES TO THE MOST MOST
VULNERABLE CALIFORNIANS. THE
REMAINING 50 COUNTIES WILL
IMPLEMENT CARE COURTS BY
DECEMBER 1ST OF THIS YEAR. SINCE
THE PROGRAM WAS LAUNCHED IN
OCTOBER, 2020 THREE. WE ARE
ALREADY SEEING SIGNIFICANT
PROMISE IN ASSISTING PEOPLE WITH
MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES. WHETHER
THESE CASES ARE FILED BY
CONCERNED FAMILY MEMBERS OR
DIRECTLY BY THOSE WHO NEED THE
SERVICES WITH HELP FROM A PUBLIC
DEFENDER. WE LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING OUR COMMITMENT TO
THIS IMPORTANT PROGRAM AND THE
PEOPLE IT SERVES WHO SO
DESPERATELY NEED ASSISTANCE.
ANOTHER PRESSING ISSUE THAT
DESERVES OUR ATTENTION IS THE
ABILITY TO SERVE LITIGANTS. BY
BEING ABLE TO PROVIDE THEM WITH
A VERBATIM RECORD OF THEIR TRIAL
COURT PROCEEDINGS. RIGHT NOW,
THAT IS NOT HAPPENING IN TOO
MANY CASES. IN JUST A THREE
MONTH PERIOD BETWEEN JULY 1ST
AND SEPTEMBER 30TH OF LAST YEAR.
NEARLY 40% OF FAMILY, PROBATE
AND UNLIMITED CIVIL HEARINGS IN
CALIFORNIA HAD NÓ VERBATIM
RECORD. THAT'S 130 THREE 1000
HEARINGS IN JUST THREE MONTHS.
WE ALL WANT AND NEED MORE
LICENSED COURT REPORTERS TO BE
TRAINED, CERTIFIED AND HIRED AND
THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL AND THE
COURTS ARE DOING ALL THAT WE
FEASIBLY CAN TO SUPPORT THAT
GOAL, INCLUDING SIGNING BONUSES.
WE HAVE RETENTION BONUSES,
LONGEVITY BONUSES, INCREASED
SALARY RANGES, FINDERS FEES AND
STUDENT LOAN OR TUITION
REIMBURSEMENT INCENTIVE. BUT THE
NUMBER OF CERTIFIED COURT
REPORTERS CONTINUES TO DECLINE
AND IT THREATENS ACCESS TO
JUSTICE, ESPECIALLY FOR
VULNERABLE CALIFORNIANS. AS OUR
COURT EXPLAINED IN 2018, IN AN
OPINION THAT WE ISSUED THE
ABSENCE OF A VERBATIM RECORD OF
TRIAL, COURT PROCEEDINGS WILL
OFTEN HAVE A DEVASTATING EFFECT
ON A LITIGANT'S ABILITY TO HAVE
AN APPEAL DECIDED ON THE MERITS.
THESE DEVASTATING EFFECTS ARE
ALREADY BEING FELT BY FAR TOO
MANY COURT USERS. I LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH YOU ALL TO FIND
PRACTICAL SOLUTIONS TO THIS
ONGOING ISSUE. THE FINAL
STRATEGIC GOAL FOR THE JUDICIAL
BRANCH THAT I WANT TO RAISE WITH
YOU IS THE GOAL OF INDEPENDENCE
AND ACCOUNTABILITY. THIS GOAL
ENCOMPASSES QUITE A BIT. IT
ENCOMPASSES THE INDEPENDENCE OF
THE JUDICIARY AS A SEPARATE AND
COEQUAL BRANCH OF GOVERNMENT.
AND THE INDEPENDENCE OF JUDICIAL
DECISION MAKING IN ORDER TO
PRESERVE THE RULE OF LAW AND
ENSURE THE FAIR AND PARTIAL AND
EFFICIENT DELIVERY OF JUSTICE.
IT ALSO INVOLVES MAINTAINING THE
HIGHEST STANDARDS OF
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR THE USE OF
PUBLIC RESOURCES AND ADHERENCE
TO STATUTORY AND CONSTITUTIONAL
MANDATE. THERE IS A NECESSARY
BALANCE BETWEEN IMPARTIALITY,
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCOUNTABILITY.
WE EMBRACE OUR OBLIGATIONS TO
DESCRIBE OUR RULINGS. BUT WHAT
CONCERNS ME ARE UNNECESSARY AND
UNPRODUCTIVE PARTISAN ATTACKS ON
COURT DECISIONS. I'M CONCERNED
THAT THESE TRENDS AND A DECLINE
IN CIVIL DISCOURSE CAN
NEGATIVELY IMPACT THE PUBLIC'S
TRUST AND CONFIDENCE IN OUR
DEMOCRATIC INSTITUTIONS. WE MUST
SAFEGUARD THE INTEGRITY OF THE
COURTS AND OUR DECISION MAKING.
OUR JUDICIARY IS NONPARTISAN.
AND ADHERES TO THE RULE OF LAW.
WE DO NOT MAKE PUBLIC POLICY. WE
EMBRACE THE ROBUST ETHICS
STANDARDS THAT WE HAVE IN PLACE
WITH SUPPORTIVE TRAINING AND
GUIDANCE. WE ALSO HAVE
MISCONDUCT OVERSIGHT FROM AN
INDEPENDENT STATE AGENCY. WE
BELIEVE IN THE VALUE OF
PRECEDENT. AND I BELIEVE THAT
HOW COURTS INTERPRET THE LAW AND
ADJUDICATE CASES SHOULDN'T
CHANGE DRAMATICALLY WHEN THE
MEMBERS OF A COURT CHANGE MM.
AND I WILL SAY AGAIN AS I DID
LAST YEAR THAT I'M PRIVILEGED TO
SERVE ON ONE OF THE MOST
TALENTED AND DIVERSE HIGH COURTS
IN THE NATION, A COLLEGIAL BENCH
WITH THE BROAD RANGE OF
BACKGROUNDS AND EXPERIENCES.
THERE HAVE BEEN A NUMBER OF
STUDIES ON OUR SUPREME COURT
OVER THIS PAST YEAR, ONE
REPORTED THAT WE HAD THE HIGHEST
UNANIMITY RATE IN THE COURT'S
RECENT HISTORY AT 94. I DON'T
KNOW IF YOU SHOULD APPLAUD, BUT.
I WILL SAY THAT'S NOT BECAUSE WE
DON'T VALUE DISSENT AND OR SHARE
ONE ANOTHER'S OPINIONS. MY
COLLEAGUES ARE NOT SHY. I THINK
THAT STATISTIC MAY CHANGE AT
SOME POINT, BUT WHAT REMAINS
CONSTANT IS OUR RESPECT FOR THE
RULE OF LAW, PRECEDENT AND
LEGISLATIVE INTENT. WE RESPECT
ONE ANOTHER'S POINTS OF VIEW AND
THE PROCESS OF DELIBERATING AND
CRAFTING AN OPINION AND WE
RESPECT ONE ANOTHER. THE
CALIFORNIA SUPREME COURT HAS A
LONG HISTORY OF SETTING
PRECEDENTS IN AREAS RELATING TO
CONSUMER PROTECTION, CRIMINAL
JUSTICE, CIVIL LIBERTIES AND
RACIAL INTEGRATION. THE
IMPORTANCE OF OUR WORK IS NOT
ALWAYS LIMITED TO OUR CASES
ALONE. IN 2020 DURING A
TURBULENT SUMMER FOR OUR NATION,
MY COLLEAGUES ON THE COURT
ISSUED A STATEMENT ON EQUALITY
AND INCLUSION THAT STILL
RESONATES TODAY. I'D LIKE TO
SHARE SOME OF THAT WITH YOU.
THEY WROTE. EACH OF US HAS A
DUTY TO RECOGNIZE THERE IS MUCH
UNFINISHED AND ESSENTIAL WORK
THAT MUST BE DONE TO MAKE
QUALITY AND INCLUSION AND
EVERYDAY REALITY FOR ALL OF WE
STATE CLEARLY AND WITHOUT
EQUIVOCATION THAT WE CONDEMN
RACISM IN ALL ITS FORMS,
CONSCIOUS, UNCONSCIOUS
INSTITUTIONAL STRUCTURAL,
HISTORIC AND CONTINUING EACH
MEMBER OF THIS COURT, ALONG WITH
THE COURT AS A WHOLE EMBRACES
THIS OBLIGATION. AS MEMBERS OF
THE LEGAL PROFESSION SWORN TO
UPHOLD OUR FUNDAMENTAL
CONSTITUTIONAL VALUES WE WILL
NOT AND MUST NOT REST. UNTIL THE
PROMISE OF EQUAL JUSTICE UNDER
THE LAW. IT'S FOR ALL OUR PEOPLE
A LIVING TRUTH. OK? I CAN TELL
YOU THAT THOSE SAME SENTIMENTS
ARE SHARED BY JUDICIAL OFFICERS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. I THINK
YOU CAN SEE WHY I'M PROUD TO
SERVE ON THIS COURT AND WITH MY
JUDICIAL BRANCH COLLEAGUES, ALL
2000 OF THEM AND 18,000 COURT
PROFESSIONALS, THE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL AND THE PROFESSIONAL
STAFF OF THE COUNCIL AND OUR
JUSTICE SYSTEM PARTNERS AND I
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
EACH OF YOU ON FUTURE
INITIATIVES AND THE PROMISE OF
EQUAL JUSTICE AND OF THE LAW FOR
ALL CALIFORNIANS. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, CHIEF JUSTICE
GUERRERO. WITHOUT OBJECTION, THE
STATE OF THE JUDICIARY ADDRESS
SHALL BE PRINTED IN THE JOURNAL
AS A SEPARATE APPENDIX. THE
CHIEF AND THE ASSOCIATE JUSTICES
OF THE SUPREME COURT MAY NOW
EXIT THE REAR OF THE CHAMBER. AS
THE JUSTICES DEPART THE CHAMBER.
I HAVE A BRIEF ANNOUNCEMENT. THE
COURT WOULD LIKE TO INVITE
MEMBERS AND INVITE A GUEST FOR
RECEPTION WITH THE CHIEF JUSTICE
ACROSS THE STREET AT THE STANLEY
MOSQUE, UH, LIBRARY AND COURTS
BUILDING IMMEDIATELY FOLLOWING
ADJOURNMENT TODAY. WE WILL NOW.
ADJOURN THE JOINT CONVENTION
SIGN AND I.
MEMBERS. WE ARE BACK IN REGULAR
SESSION. MEMBERS WE'RE BACK IN
REGULAR SESSION SESSION SCHEDULE
IS AS FOLLOWS WEDNESDAY, MARCH
20TH CHECK IN SESSION THURSDAY,
MARCH 20TH FLOOR SESSION AT 9
A.M. ALL OTHER ITEMS REMAINING
WILL BE PASSED AND RETAINED. ALL
MOTIONS SHALL BE CONTINUED SEEN
IN HEARING NÓ FURTHER BUSINESS.
I'M READY TO ADJOURN A MOTION TO
ADJOURN. MS AGUIAR-CURRY MOVES,
MR GALLAGHER. SECONDS AT THIS
HOUSE STANDS ADJOURNED UNTIL
THURSDAY, MARCH 21ST AT 9 A.M.
THE QUORUM CALL IS LIFTED AND
THE HOUSE IS ADJOURNED.